I would like everybody to to uh to try
and laugh without smiling Hannah doing
this I am do you want to see the replay
you are I can't I can't do it oh this is
like how dead your eyes are I want all
girlfriends to tell me that after dates
I didn't think I would hate it as much
as I do but I hate it so much I feel
like I'm killing my heart what weird
experiment are you putting me through
right now
seems weird like a creeper you're going
insane
you to get him actually solve this oh
I'm so creeped up I'm I saw a cannon she
may face something I'm crying tricks on
you I've never laughed in my life and I
just you know make that noise and
everyone believes it ha ha ha ha ha ha
that's uncomfortable ha ha I feel sad
wait am I supposed to try to laugh
without
I didn't spit on you the whole laughing
a lot smiling thing it's been done
before and something that they do in the
VidCon office all the time to relieve
stress to make each other laugh to make
themselves laugh I think that's what I
like about it is a lot of the time you
start out fake laughing and then it
makes you real laugh and real laughing
is nice and the VidCon team right now is
in Anaheim doing all the checkups and
visits and meetings and stuff that we
need to do getting ready for VidCon
which is happening earlier this year
it's June 24th you'd think I'd know June
23rd to 25th so I was right kind if you
like online video VidCon is a thing that
we do I hope you can come so glad I got
to see all those people while I was in
LA well great there's lots of them and I
put links to all their channels in the
description there was one person you
didn't see in the video laughing without
smiling so let's do that while I link to
all the other collab videos that I was
in while I was in LA the ones that have
come out so far at least here we go John
I'll see you on Tuesday